hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers infinity
war surprised us with a new shorter
trailer but even at 30 seconds this
thing is packed with miserable details
it's a normal full trailer I guess
considering all of the MCU heroes are
part of this it's hard to include a shot
without one of them sneaking into frame
with a cool new suitor mysterious Skaar
game-changing weapon I guess that's
excluding no shows like Hawkeye and
ant-man maybe they're just hiding behind
the Marvel logo like Mike Wazowski all
right you know the drill I'm gonna break
this down shot by shot point out several
bombshells in this Avengers trailer hi
am I being hyperbolic calling plot clues
in a comic book movie trailer bombshells
maybe
don't judge me potential spoiler warning
ahead and let's get started with this
first half so this is it it's all in
leave us
ready let's go okay first we see Iron
Man Peter Parker and Stephen strange the
MC Trinity if you will or just three
well liked Marvel characters now I'm
assuming this is a little ways into the
movie Stark and Peter have already
suited up in their new armor and it
seems like this movie will take a moment
to introduce this stuff to us but to me
the bigger question is where are they
well look closely that blue lighting in
the background this looks very similar
to that possible as guardianship setting
that we saw Loki in in the previous
trailer when he was handing over the
tesseract by the way I already did a
super in-depth breakdown in that
trailers to go make sure to watch it so
you know what I'm talking about anyway I
think these three are witnessing that
event maybe they travelled through some
rift in reality using strangest powers
may be that big mysterious ring floating
over New York but the theory I'm leaning
most toward is that all of this is barf
yep Bart if all this is gratuitous
fanservice Li grosses me out Worf no no
barf binary augmented retro framing Tony
Stark's hologram memory technology that
we saw in Captain America's Civil War
the directors a Russo brothers hinted
that a piece of technology introduced in
civil war would come back and play a
major role in this movie so I think
Stark could be using his barf tech to go
inside Bruce banners memories from when
he was the Hulk on the as guardianship
at the end of Thor Ragnarok to witness a
projected recording of the moment Loki
screwed them over and Thanos his forces
acquired the space stone of course there
could be wrong so let me know what you
think we're seeing here in the comments
below but next up there's more of
Scarlet Witch Wanda Maximoff consoling
vision inhuman Paul Bettany looking for
me it's hard to tell exactly what she's
doing here maybe she's using her powers
to examine the mine stone in his
forehead reading it like a palm reader
would read palms to predict Thanos
coming for it or this could take place
after vision has had his mind stone
clawed out of his head and Wanda is just
sweetly materializing a new fake one
made out of energy and reinserting it in
his head you know to make him feel
better like kissing a boo boo I don't
know this just seems like a really
intimate moment I like that detail of
the tiny hair on Paul Bettany's head
bending forward as if attracted to the
electricity between these lovers or just
static electricity in either case I'm
thinking vision losing the mine stone
will cause kind of an existential crisis
for him like
maybe he'll feel like he lost his soul
and he'll have to learn that while the
mine stone was one of the ingredients
that brought him into the world it
doesn't define who he is now next we see
the guardians of the galaxy star-lord
Gomorrah and Drax stepping off the
Milano and later a different shot of
Thor with rocket and teenage grew to
love how he's distracted on his phone
there looks like they're headed
somewhere else maybe the guardians are
gonna be splitting off on different
tasks but more on that later then we see
Peter Parker clinging to the giant ring
structure that we saw in the last
trailer but here this thing has risen
way higher above Manhattan and Peter's
still wearing his own spider-man suit he
rips off his mask and gasps for air
probably because the air is so thin up
there and he can't breathe so I think
what we're gonna see here is after Peter
sees that thing on his way to school he
swings in to investigate but then it
shoots up into the sky and Stark has to
send in the pressurized iron spider suit
to attach to Peter and wrap around him
which I'm thinking is what we saw the
finished result of in the last trailer I
just think this all suggests to us how
much under thread all these heroes are
they're gonna have to stay suited up for
the entire movie because they never know
when danger will strike okay next up it
looks like cap and black widow are
returning to Avengers headquarters and
behind Natasha you can see vision
holding himself as if he's wounded but
mine stone no longer in his forehead so
I guess the takeaway here is that vision
losing his mind stone won't kill him
it'll just leave them little rattled
forcing the Avengers to regroup along
with some new friends look closely
behind cap there's another person there
now you can see this person's hand as it
swings down and if you look over to the
right there's a reflection in the glass
that shows an outline with long hair you
can also see a gold-colored pattern on
this person's suit and a bluish color on
the thigh guys I'm thinking we're
looking at Captain Marvel here you know
but in a new suit that isn't like weird
and green my guess is kind of like how
they introduced Black Panther in Civil
War they're gonna backdoor Captain
Marvel in this movie and set her up for
her own solo film next year I get this
quick shot of Thor more thoughts on him
in a second but then there's caps
showing us the new shield to chawla
teased in the last trailer of a Condon
designed retractable vibranium shield
gauntlet and looks like it would provide
him with a lot less cover than his round
shield would but I could see Kat picking
this out to be
more tactical in the battle he's about
to fight against the outriders like I
would say he would need something a bit
more lightweight with some sharper
points to jab with meanwhile based on
set photos that have leaked at some
point we will see cap in his classic
Stars and Stripes at some point in this
movie or an infinity War part two during
which I assume we will see him reunited
with this round shield but let's move on
to the second half of this trailer
[Music]
okay in this part we see Tony Stark's
new Ironman armor which spreads and
assembles across his body now this looks
like the closest thing we've gotten in
the MCU to the long-anticipated
bleeding-edge armor from the comics
which is based on nanobots inside Tony
skin which emerged in assemble as his
armor but if you're looking at this
closely this does look a bit different
from that this armor doesn't appear to
be bleeding out of his skin so much as
it's really just crawling across his
shoulder and neck with each piece of it
building on the last piece this could
just be an extrapolation from the armor
assembling out of his wristwatch in
civil war may be combined with the tech
of sharees new black panther suit which
emits from the necklace in this case
maybe this armor emits from Tony's new
chest piece next there's a shot of
teenage Groot and if you look behind him
there's a large ring device that looks
similar to the one for grabs on to in
the previous trailer also in that shot
that we saw earlier where he looks if it
says ready it looks like he was standing
in that thing now it's rumored that Thor
will get a new hammer in this movie
since the last meal near was destroyed
by hella and Ragnarok a while back
concept art for this movie showed Thor
wheeled in some new version of MIL near
and chris hemsworth posted on social
media a photo of him with the ultimate
version the hammer from the comics
that's part battle ax and more recently
there was the leaked image of a Funko
pop Thor for this movie with Thor
holding his new hammer that's right guys
the secrets always in the toys so anyway
maybe that's what Thor is doing here
with Groot and Rocket forging his new
hammer next there's a shot of nebula the
background looks similar to some of
those battle shots with stark and
spider-man in the last trailer at the
time I suggested that this could be the
ruins of Xand are the home of the Nova
Corps from the guardians of the galaxy
which Stannis probably would destroy to
give us hands-on the power stone that
was kept there then a few shots of this
battle in Wakanda the wave of outriders
Black Widow riding with adorable RJ and
Bucky now if you look closely the
wakandans have designed for him a new
vibranium arm and in a masala to keeping
that bounce in his hair following this
is this interesting shot of Doctor
Strange harnessing a spell with Iron Man
just swooping in and pushing right
through it now I don't think Stark is
screwing up this attack on accident'
this seems deliberate this could just be
a teamwork moment like maybe dr. strange
is holding this
mystical energy football and Stark is
coming in with those repulsors to take
it through the uprights
or maybe Stark doesn't want strange to
use this spell maybe strange is trying
to attack cap or vision or Scarlet Witch
and Stark is telling him to stand down
or maybe Stark is worried that whatever
spell strange casts my back fire from
Thanos his forces so he's trying to help
his buddy out let me know what you think
is happening here in the comments but
then after another quick look at that
great team-up charge we close on this
menacing shot up thanasis space now a
lot of you guys pointed out to me those
lines on Thanos his cheeks suggesting
their scars maybe from caps new
vibranium gauntlet or Black Panthers
claws some are even saying those scars
could come from Wolverine whoo now that
Marvel has regained the movie rights the
character with this Disney Fox merger
could make a cameo in some upcoming MCU
property look all of those options sound
awesome to me I'm fascinated to see how
any of these characters could leave a
mark on Thanos except know people that
studio merger is still very much a work
in progress and infinity war has been in
a can for quite a bit now so yeah I
wouldn't expect Wolverine to pop up here
more importantly Thanos has had those
lines on his face for a while now at
least since we saw that good look of
them in guardians of the galaxy I don't
know maybe in the MCU we'll see some
very interesting backstory as to how he
got them but I don't think it'll come
from any of the Avengers in this war it
breaks my heart to extinguish a good
theory fire but guys we have to appeal
to reason at some point but a question I
want to leave you guys with what could
that OSes weakness be also now that it
looks like Captain Marvel will appear in
this movie how do you think Avengers
infinity war will work Captain Marvel
into the story comment down below with
what you think and your thoughts on
those other mysteries from this trailer
down below or tweet me directly I da vas
and follow the new rock stars on Twitter
for updates under videos and yeah if you
haven't already go check on my breakdown
on the first infinity war trailer for
more details about this movie subscribe
to new rock stars for breakdowns and
deep dives and all the stuff you love
clewd and all the other trailers
released during this big game including
solo a Star Wars story of Antonov Queen
breakdowns we have for Westworld season
2 trailer and drastic world falling
Kingdom and if you really want help us
grow you can contribute to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our donors
especially Pony star thanks for watching
guys bye